desde el aeropuerto ben-gurion en israel
hasta el aeropuerto de bandama en
bahrein un avión llevó a yair lapid a la
primera visita oficial de un ministro de
exteriores israelí a un estado del golfo
en su cuenta de 'twitter' y en árabe
lápiz celebró la visita
extiendo mi más sincero agradecimiento a
su majestad el rey hamad bin isa al
jalifa por este encuentro histórico
íntimo y esperanzador el liderazgo y la
inspiración de su majestad han llevado a
una verdadera cooperación conjunta y
esta reunión trazó el camino para
continuar nuestras relaciones el oficial
israelí fue recibido por el ministro de
relaciones exteriores de bahréin
abdüllatif al-zayani una visita de un
solo día en la cual inaugurará la
embajada israelí en manama y firmará
convenios de cooperación pero más allá
de los intereses comerciales que unen a
las dos naciones son sus preocupaciones
comunes en cuanto a irán que siguen
siendo el punto más importante de hecho
este tema fue una de las razones
principales de la normalización de las
relaciones entre israel y algunos
estados del golfo
entre tanto la visita del lápiz no fue
celebrada por todo el mundo en las
afueras de la capital de bahréin
manifestantes quemaron neumáticos
mientras que una campaña contra la
normalización de las relaciones con
israel fue difundida en las redes
sociales
en septiembre de 2020 bahréin se unió a
la firma de los llamados acuerdos de
abraham impulsados por la administración
de donald trump israel estableció
entonces relaciones diplomáticas con
cuatro países árabes entre ellos
emiratos árabes unidos- hasta ese
momento sólo egipto y jordania habían
reconocido al estado judío en
1974 y
1994 respectivamente
la administración de job aiden también
ha celebrado el enfoque de la
normalización entre israel y los países
árabes